Everyone and welcome back [music] to
Yahoo Finance Live. I'm Alexis
Kristoffus here with Karina Mitchell and
Berkshire Hathaway's number two Charlie
Munger about to speak at the Daily
Journal's annual meeting in Los Angeles.
Munger of course is the chairman of the
board of the Daily Journal and he'll
also be taking shareholder questions.
And Karina, you know, normally hundreds
of investors from all over the country
attend this meeting to hear Charlie.
Yeah, absolutely, Alexis. And this year
due to co the meeting is being held at
the Daily Journal's downtown offices in
LA. It's one of those rare appearances
where you get to hear Munger speak
candidly about the markets and the
economy. So without further ado, let's
go straight to LA to hear from Charlie
Mer and Daily Journal President and CEO
Jerry Saltzman. Gentlemen, thank you so
much. Charlie, the floor is yours.
Charlie, the floor is yours.
The sole business of the meeting is to
elect four directors.
Mer [clears throat]
Conland,
Mary Joe Rodriguez, and John Frank. We
have the proxies. We have the inspector
of elections. We have everything here.
That is now done. The m the Daily
Journal's formeral business is over. Now
we're going to answer questions. in the
tradition that's come to both the Daily
Journal and Bergkshire Hathaway. So,
you're you're on for the first question.
CNBC and I've been collecting
shareholder questions. We'll go through
as many as we can over this period, but
uh Charlie Jerry, we wanted to start
with questions that were very specific
to the Daily Journal first. First
question comes in from someone who asked
to remain anonymous. But the first part
of the question is, how does the Daily
Journal plan to handle its investment
portfolio after Charlie steps back?
Charlie, I think you should answer that.
Well, we'll I'll handle it as long as we
can and when I'm gone or sufficiently
impaired, we'll get somebody else to do
it.
Okay. Hey, the second question, second
part of that question is what are the
reasons for Jerry and Peter Kaufman
leaving the board?
Well, we are going to have to make
changes in the future
uh because our Jerry and I are so
superanuated
and
uh
Peter didn't want to do it anymore
and that's all we have to say.
The next question comes in from Sarah
Anderson and again these succession
questions we I did receive several of
them so I just wanted to follow up with
this one. She asks, "What is the current
Daily Journal's management succession
plan and who will be in charge after Mr.
Salsman's retirement?"
Well, our long-term plan are replace
both Jerry and I because he's 83 and I'm
98.
So obviously we have a succession
planning to do in the near future and
we'll do it as fast as we can.
The next question that comes in is from
someone who says he's a concerned
shareholder. His name is Frankie Lamb.
He says, "I noticed that our company is
using margin debts to purchase overseas
securities and the overseas security is
not reported in the SEC filing. As a
shareholder, am I entitled to know what
overseas security we own on margin?
Thank you for taking my question.
Well, the practice at Daily Journal and
Berkshire is the same. We disclose what
we have to under the rules because we
don't want people to know what we're
buying and selling. So, we tell
everybody what we have to under the
rules and we and we keep it
confidential until then. That's our
system.
This question comes in from Daniel Koig.
He says, "I am a small retail
shareholder from Austria and I have
basically only one question. In the
latest 10Q, our company stated that
Journal Technologies serves 30 states in
the United States. On the website and
all the other older 10Q and 10Ks, it
said that JT serves 42 states. I just
wonder what is the reason for the
decline. I would appreciate any
explanation.
I'd appreciate any explanation.
Jerry, you take that one.
The reason for the decline
to a certain degree is several years ago
we decided not to support a very old
legacy system
which had a number of smaller agencies
in addition to a number of larger
agencies.
And as as we expected
the many of the smaller agencies
decided
not to go to our
main system which we call ecort e
systems e
probation e
prosecutor and e public defender. And so
that's the reason the decline in those
numbers.
And by the way, other software companies
avoid obsoleting a system because they
lose some business, but we want the the
customers to have the more more modern
system.
A related follow-up question on that
comes from Jim Mitchell in Costa Mesa.
He says, um, who are your principal
competitors in supplying software to
court systems? And do you have a guess
as to who has what market share?
Well, Journal Technologies has the big
share
and
the rest is scattered.
Not pardon me. I mean Tyler Technologies
has the big market share.
Jim Hall writes in and says, "Mr.
Munger, I've been a shareholder of the
Daily Journal for over 20 years and
appreciate the quality of the management
and the employees in developing the
business. In the annual report, you
noted that the prospects in software now
seem especially interesting. Would you
care to expound on that thought?
Well, I'm glad to. What's interesting is
that
the courts of the world have been in the
stone age and
there's no reason where lawyers should
go down through heavy traffic and wait
for some little motion. It should all be
done on Zoom and so forth. And the
filing should be done electronically. in
it. So the
what there is is a huge market for the
automation of the courts and it's early.
That's the good news. It's a big market.
The bad news is it's a slow damn tough
way to grind ahead in software because
it's very bureaucratic
RFP government bodies
and it's just
it's a huge market and it's
intrinsically going to be very slow to
get done.
That's the good news and bad news. We
have a huge market and it's going to be
slow and bureaucratic.
Okay, the next question comes in from
happen. There's any doubt about what's
going to happen. The courts are going to
get more efficient and get with the
modern world.
Okay,
and so also the district attorney's
offices and the probation offices.
Uh the next question comes from Tom
Seymour. He writes in in January, Jeff
Gunlack was quoted, "China is
uninvestable in my opinion at this
point. I've never invested China long or
short. Why is that? I don't trust the
data. I don't trust the relationship
between the United States and China
anymore. I think that investments in
China could be confiscated. I think
there's a risk of that." End quote.
Obviously, with a significant percentage
of the Daily Journal's marketable
securities invested in BYYD and Alibaba,
you feel differently. Please explain why
you are right.
Explain why you are right.
Well, of course, only the future knows
who's going to be right.
But China is a big modern nation. It's
got this huge population and this huge
modernity that's come in the last 30
years. And
we invested some money in China because
we could get more value in terms of the
strength of the enterprise and the price
of the security than we could get in the
United States.
Other people, including Sequoia, the
leading venture capital firm in the
United States, have made the same
decision we have.
But I'm sympathetic to Gunlike. He's
nervous, he doesn't have to join us.
Different different folks have different
opinions.
I feel about Russia the way he feels
about China. I don't invest in Russia.
So I I can't criticize Gunlock's point
of view. It's just I reached a different
conclusion.
Okay. This question comes in from Bill
Roberts. Um, and he says, "Charlie, you
and Warren have been making concentrated
investments since the 1950s. Many of
these investments have led to gains, but
even more impressively, none of them
have led to significant losses. As far
as I can tell, neither one of you has
lost more than a few percentage points
of equity on any single investment.
Daily Journal has recently bet a large
amount of its capital on Alibaba and
foreign traded stock. It's also taken on
an additional $40 million in margin debt
to make these investments. What makes
you so sure that these investments won't
lead to a substantial impairment of
Daily Journal's equity capital, which
would impact the company's ability to
reinvest the resources needed to develop
the company's software operating
business?
Well, of course, if you invest in
marketable securities, you have the risk
that they'll go down and you'll lose
money instead of make it. But the if you
hold a depreciating currency, that's
losing purchasing power. On balance, we
prefer the risks we have to those we're
avoiding. And we don't mind a tiny
little bit of margin debt.
I got lots and lots of questions on
Alibaba. That was the one question that
I received more than any other. So, I'll
dig a little deeper through some of
these. Um, someone named Vashal Patel
from Toronto wrote in and said that as a
Daily Journal owner, do we own local
shares of Alibaba? Does that actually
give us legal ownership of that business
or do we have a variable interest? And
is that the same net net? What do we
own? And I did get a series of questions
related to that same uh sort of sort of
thought.
When you buy Alibaba, you do get a sort
of a derivative,
but assuming there's a reasonable honor
among
civilized nations,
uh, that risk doesn't seem all that big
to me.
I got a lot of questions just about the
investing in China risks and I'll I'll
ask this one from Ravi Meta. Um he's
interested in your take on China and
Chinese stock exposure for the long
term. He says it's becoming quite
evident that Chinese companies could be
banned from doing business in the
Western world or maybe some of the
eastern countries too because of the
number of the following reasons. One,
the security threat issues. Two, the
potential conflict over Taiwan. Three,
inability to meet Western accounting
standards. And number four, human rights
issues. Considering all of the risks
mentioned above, why would anyone as
smart as Munger or Buffett consider
investing in China or any of the Chinese
companies?
Well, we did it for a very simple
reason. We got more
strength per dollar invested
in China. This the companies we invest
in are stronger relative to their
competition and priced lower. That's why
we're in China.
U this one came in from Wasim. He said,
"Although the financials seem strong, do
the political pressures from the Chinese
government worry you um at all?"
Well, the Chinese government is worrying
all the capitalists in the world way
more than it used to.
And of course, we don't like that. And
we wish that China and the United States
got along better. And
if you stop to think about it,
think of how massively stupid both China
and the United States have been to allow
the existing tensions to arise. What bad
is ever going to happen to China or the
United States if if we two are close
if we make good friends out of the
Chinese and vice versa. Who in the hell
is ever going to bother us? Of course we
should make friends with China. And of
course we should learn to get along with
people who have a different system of
government.
it. We like our government because we're
used to it and it has advantages of
personal freedom. China could never have
handled its life with a government like
ours. They wouldn't they wouldn't be in
the position they they're in. They had
to prevent 500 million or 600 million
people from born in China. They just
measured the women's menstrual periods
when they came to work and aborted those
who weren't allowed to have children.
You can't do that in the United States
and it really needed doing in China and
so they did what they had to do using
their methods and I don't think we
should be
criticizing China which which has
terrible problems because they're not
just like the United States. They do
some things better than we do.
They should like us and we should like
them. So I'm I'm totally I think nothing
is crazier than people who fment
resentments on either side of that one.
Another shareholder uh named Lee Li
wrote in and said, "How do you think the
Ukraine situation will be resolved in
your opinion?"
Well, I have no insight that's any
better than anybody else on that one.
Most of these things in the days when
both parties have huge numbers of
hydrogen bombs get resolved because the
alternative is so awful that even an
idiot can see that the question ought to
be resolved.
That's the way it's worked so far and I
hope it keeps working that way. We live
in the pox nucleana. [clears throat]
We've gotten an absence of world wars
for a long time because we had these
nuclear weapons. It's been a blessing to
humanity, but it does make you nervous
every once in a while. And it's quite
irresponsible when the
when the leaders in the modern age get
over tensions over border incidents and
so forth.
You said that we should partner up with
with China. Does it concern you to see
Russia partnering up with China and that
relationship getting a little closier?
It's hardly think of anything that's
more stupid. And both sides are doing
it. The political leaders on each side
are trying to make points with their own
constituencies by showing how tough they
are. That is massively stupid on both
sides.
Uh, another question came in on Alibaba
and I know that we've covered a lot of
ground on this. I'll ask that because
it's it's slightly different. This one
comes from John Mooney in Marshfield,
Massachusetts, and he says, "Charlie,
Alibaba is a top three holding for you.
It sells at a steep discount to its US
peers. Best comparable is Amazon, which
is triple Alibaba's PE. So, what
discount should should US investors seek
when buying Chinese stocks? Considering
the political, regulatory, and
especially the ownership structure
risk?" Oh, and considering the fortune
Bergkshire made on your BYD suggestion,
why doesn't Buffer buy Alibaba?
Well,
Warren, like many other intelligent
people, likes to invest where he's
personally comfortable.
And for some reason, I'm more
comfortable with the Chinese than he is.
That's a minor
difference.
And
but I have all kinds of places where I'm
just like war. And I have all kinds of
things where I'm not comfortable and I
just don't go near them. I think an old
guy's entitled to invest where he wants
to invest in.
What makes you uncomfortable? What do
you not
It's okay to have some things which you
just don't want to bother with.
Like uh
like crypto. Oh, I got
I don't think Alibaba is is as is I
don't think Alibaba is as entrenched as
something like Apple on Alphabet.
I think the internet is going to be a
very competitive place even if you're a
big internet retailer.
Uh Charlie, crypto was another question
that I got a lot of. I I'll ask this one
from Carl Mos Moscetello who says,
"Crypto is a $2 trillion asset class.
Are you willing to admit you missed
something?"
Well, I certainly didn't invest in
crypto.
I'm proud of the fact I've avoided it.
It's like,
you know, some venerial disease or
something. I just regard it as beneath
contempt. Some people think it's
modernity and they welcome a
currency that's so useful in extortions
and kidnappings and
so on and so on, tax evasion
and
it and of course the envy everybody has
to create his own new
currency
and I think that's crazy too. So,
I'm I'm not having any I wish it had
been banned immediately and I admire the
Chinese for banning it. I think they
were right and we we've been wrong to
allow it.
Perhaps this is the appropriate
follow-up then. This comes from Micah
Meek who asks, "Mr. Mer, you've been
warning of the evil evils of
cryptocurrency in the past. How do you
feel about the Federal Reserve preparing
to launch a central bank digital
currency? Do you think that this will be
beneficial or harmful to the strength
and resilience of our markets?
No. No. The Federal Reserve could have a
currency if they want one. That that
would be just a We've got a digital
currency already. It's called a bank
account. The banks are all integrated
with the Federal Reserve system.
We already have a digital currency.
All right, let's talk about broader
markets in the United States. This is
another question from Tom Seymour who
sent in several that were pretty good.
Um, this one he says, "Two years ago at
this meeting, you said, "I think there
are lots of troubles coming. There's too
much wretched excess." Since that
meeting, we have seen something like 860
spaxs, IPOs like Rivian and Robin Hood,
and the GameStop phenomenon. I can't
imagine you've changed your mind. I
wonder what your favorite story of
wretched excess is from the last year.
Well, certainly
the great short squeeze in GameStop was
wretched excess. Certainly [snorts] the
Bitcoin thing is wretched excess.
Um,
I would argue that venture capital is
throwing too much money too fast in and
there's a considerable wretched excess
in venture capital and other forms of
private equity. And so
we have a stock market
which some people use like a gambling
parlor and the transactions of the
people who love the gambling parlor
aspect of the business and those who
want to make long-term investments to
take care of their old age and so forth.
I mean, you model it in one market
and it goes out of control because the
the stock market becomes an ideal
gambling parlor activity.
I don't think that ought to have been
allowed either. If I were the dictator
of the world,
I would have some kind of attacks on
short-term gains that made the stock
market very much less liquid
and and drove out this this marriage of
gambling parlor and legitimate
capital development of the country. It's
not a good marriage and I think we need
a divorce.
How would a divorce work?
Well, you'd have to have some kind of a
rule that that just
made stocks way less liquid.
We have all the real estate we want, all
the shopping centers and auto agencies
and so forth, without having a perfect
liquid market. We could we would have a
stock market that was way less liquid.
When I was young, we had a stock market
that was way one way less liquid, way
fewer shares. When I was at the Harvard
Law School, we seldom traded a million
shares in a day. Now we trade billions.
We don't need a stock market that
liquid.
What we're getting is wretched excess
and danger for the country. And
everybody loves it because it's like a
bunch of people get drunk at a party.
They're having so much fun getting drunk
that they don't think about the
consequences.
We don't need this wretched excess.
It has bad consequences. You can argue
that that the wretched excesses of the
20s gave us the Great Depression and the
Great Depression gave us Hitler.
This is serious stuff. You we we we
should but it's awfully hard. A lot of
people like a
a drunken brawl and and so far those are
the people that are winning and a lot of
people are making money out of our
brawl.
Um Mark Lazaro writes in with an
additional question on the markets. He
said, "You mentioned we're in a big
bubble. Can you elaborate on that and
how is this likely to play out?
Well, I think eventually there'll be
considerable trouble because of the
wretched excess. That's the way it's
usually worked in the past.
But when it's going to come and how bad
it will be, I can't tell you.
Mike Branch from Buchanan, Michigan
writes in and he says, "Charts,
technicals, momentum, and AI seem to
dominate the market these days. Are old
school Ben Graham valuation methods
dead?
They'll never die. You can't. The idea
of getting more value than you pay for.
That's what investment is. If you want
to be successful, you have to get more
value than you pay for.
And so it's never going to be obsolete.
Now, you can get a whole body of people
that I don't even know what they're
buying. They're just they're just quote
quotations on the ticker.
I don't think it's helpful to have
think of the past crazy booms and how
they worked out. The South Seas bubble,
the bubble in the late 20s, so on and so
on. We We've had this since the dawn of
capitalism. We've had crazy bubbles.
Uh Leonard Macowski writes in. He says
he's a mechanical engineer from Germany.
He said the last year's been challenging
for him because he started working
full-time while raising a fouryear-old,
finishing his PhD and supporting his
wife for her state examination. But he
said it really helped him stay rational,
humorous, and cheerful by listening to
your interviews, speeches, and questions
and answers on a daily basis. So he
wants to thank you for being such an
insightful, generous, straightforward
and honest speaker. His question is, do
you think it's likely that we will
experience a major increase in interest
rates in the upcoming decades? Like for
example, in the period between 1950 and
1980?
Well, that of course is a very
intelligent question and a very
difficult question.
When you throw money, when you print
money on the scale that modern nations
are printing it, Japan,
the United States,
Europe, etc.
We're getting into new territory in
terms of size. The Japanese bought back
not only a lot of their own debt, but a
lot of their common stocks. to the
Federal Reserve system. You can't
imagine how much money printing Japan
has done. They haven't had all that much
inflation and they
it's still a very admirable
civilization.
In fact, you you could argue that Japan
is one of the more admirable
civilizations in the whole world.
And in spite of all this very extreme
uh government money printing they've
done and they haven't had terrible
consequences. Now they've had 25 years
of stasis with living standards not
improving very much. I don't think that
came from their macroeconomic policies.
I think that came from the rise of tough
competition for their export powerhouse
from from China and Korea.
But at any rate, it's weird what's
happening and nobody knows for sure how
it's going to work out.
Uh I think it's encouraging that Japan
can print as much money as it has and
remain as civilized and calm and and
admirable as it has. And so I hope to
God the United States is similar happy
outcome. But I think the Japanese are
better adapted
for stasis than we are.
I think it's a dutyfilled civilized
bunch of people. A lot of them older,
not many young people. And and they just
suck it in and cope.
In our country, we have terrible
tensions. It's way harder to run a
country which is not monoethnic like
Japan.
There's some professor at Harvard that
has written extensively on this subject.
It's way harder to run a nation like the
United States with different ethnicities
and groups and so forth than it is to
run Japan. There are Japan is basically
sort of a monoethnic civilization which
is proud of its ethnicity and of course
they can cope with it troubles more than
better than some other people can
uh Charlie Steve
we don't know where we're going there's
we there's never anything quite like
what we're doing now and
we do know from what's happened in other
nations if you if you try and print too
much money, it eventually causes
terrible trouble. And we are closer to
terrible trouble than than we've been in
the past, but it may still be a long way
off. I certainly hope so.
Me, too. Um, Steve Caspel writes in on
on this same subject. He he says, "What
are your current thoughts on the
inflationary environment, and please
compare and contrast it to the 1970s?
Well,
when we when Vulker after the 70s
took the prime rate to 20% and the
government was paying 15% on its
government bonds.
That was a horrible recession. Lasted a
long time. Caught with a lot of a agony.
And I certainly hope we're never we're
not going there again.
I think the
I think conditions that allowed Vulkar
to do that without an interference from
the politicians
were very unusual
and I think it
in 2020 hindsight it was a good thing
that he did it. I would not predict that
our modern politicians will be as
willing to permit a new vulkar to get
that tough with the economy and bring on
that kind of a recession.
So I think the new troubles are likely
to be different from the old troubles.
This is related. These are all
you may wish you had a vuler you may
wish you had a vulker style recession
instead of what you're going to get. The
troubles that come to us could be worse
than what Vulkar was dealing with
and harder to fix.
Like what have you?
Well, think of all the think of all the
Latin American countries that print too
much money. They get strong men and so
forth. That's what Plato said happened
in the early Greek city-state
democracies.
one person, one vote, a lot of egality,
and you get demagogues, and the demogs
lather up the population, and pretty
soon you don't have your democracy
anymore.
I I don't think that was a crazy idea on
Plato's part. I think that accurately
described what happened in Greece way
back then. And and it's happened again
and again, again in Latin America. We
don't want to go there.
At least I don't.
Me neither. [laughter]
Me neither.
Um,
yeah,
Charlie, I'm gonna ask a couple of more
of these inflation questions because
it's in a similar vein, but they're
they're nuanced and there's slightly
different aspects. This is something uh
from Simon Jacobs who says conventional
economic theory argues that excessive
monetary and fiscal stimulus over the
last two years has triggered the highest
inflation in 40 years. Do you broadly
agree with this thesis? And more
importantly, do you think there will be
a high economic price to pay as the Fed
attempts to bring inflation back under
control? I guess um the reasons for it
um
well the first part I agree with that
we've done something we've done
something pretty extreme
and we don't know how bad the troubles
will be, whether we're going to be like
Japan or or something a lot worse. And
what makes life interesting is we don't
know how it's going to work out.
I think we do know we're flirting with
serious trouble.
I think we also know that some of our
earlier fears were
were overblown.
Japan is still existing as a civilized
nation
in spite of unbelievable
excess by all former standards in terms
of money printing. Think of how
seductive it is. You have a bunch of
interest bearing debts and you pay them
off with checking accounts which you're
no longer paying interest. Think of how
seductive that is for a bunch of
legislators.
You get rid of the interest payments and
you just the money supply goes up. It
seems like heaven.
And of course, when things get that
seductive, they're likely to be
overused.
Stephen Tedar from Atlanta writes in um
he had similar concerns about inflation,
but he takes it a step further. He says,
"How will this all play out? And what's
the best advice you have for individual
investors to optimally deal with the
negative impact of inflation other than
owning quality equities?"
Well,
It may be that you have to choose the
least bad of your a bunch of options.
That frequently happens in human
decision making. And
the mongers have Bergkshire stock,
Costco stock, Chinese stock through
Leelu,
uh a little bit of Daily Journal stock,
and a bunch of apartment houses. Do I
think that's perfect? No. Do I think
it's okay? Yes. I think the great lesson
from the mongers is you don't need all
this damn diversification. That's plenty
of You're lucky if you've got four good
assets.
I think the finance professors and the
that sell the idea that perfect
diversification is professional
investment.
If you're trying to do better than
average, you're lucky if you have four
things to buy. And to ask for 20 is
really asking for egg in your beer. It's
it's
very few people get can have enough
brains to get 20 good investments.
[laughter]
[gasps]
Um
this question comes in from
this question comes in
Naresh Desai in Singapore. He says, "Can
you please ask Charlie Munger which part
of Berkshire Hathaway bought the
Activision stake and if Bergkshire had
any inkling about the likely Microsoft
bid for Activision Blizzard?"
I've got no comment about that except
that I really like Bobby Kotek who's one
of the smartest business executives I
know
and I do think gaming is here to stay.
And but there again, I'm an old man. I
don't like a bunch of addicted young
males spending
40 hours a week playing games on the TV.
It does not strike me as a a good result
for civilization.
I don't like anything which is so
addictive that you probablyly give up
everything else to do it.
Well, then you're going to love this
next question that comes from Muhammad
Mia. He says, "Longtime admirer of
Charlie Munger here. Could you please
ask his views on the metaverse and the
recent acquisition of Activision
Blizzard? Was this something that
Charlie Mer had any input on? Does he
think that there is value in the
metaverse or is this something similar
to the Bitcoin and cryptocurrency hype?
Well,
without any metaverse, just the existing
technology of games on the internet,
uh, Activision, Blizzard, and a lot of
other companies have gotten very large.
And some of the games are kind of
constructive and social, and others are
very peculiar. Do you really want some
guy 40 hours a week running a machine
gun on this television set?
I don't.
But a lot of the games are harmless
pleasure. It's just a different
technique of doing it. I like the part
of it's constructive, but I I I don't
like it when people spend 40 hours a
week being an artificial machine gunner.
That's understandable. Um,
pass writes in a question um about
antitrust. He says, "Recent appointees
Lena Khan as chair of the FTC and
Jonathan Caner as assistant attorney
general of the antitrust division of the
Justice Department have each pledged to
follow an aggressive approach to
antitrust enforcement. Do you believe
there's a need for new antitrust
legislation and or more stringent
antitrust scrutiny with respect to the
largest technology companies? the
largest technology.
Well,
I think what's happened is so important
and so tied up with national strength
that I'm not trying to weaken the
internet companies of the United States.
I like the fact that we have strong
national champions that are big strong
companies and I think other nations are
proud of their big strong companies too.
So
I don't think bigness is bad in the end.
I think each
I don't want the whole internet to be
dominated by foreign companies. I want
big strong American companies
that stand well in the world. So, I'm
not as worried about
antitrust
aspects of the internet.
Are you worried about the aspects of
antitrust breaking it down though?
Well, there's no question about they're
going to get more attacks from the
present administrators than they got
from the previous ones.
That doesn't worry me that much. No, I
don't think it'll have that much
practical consequence.
There's another question that came in
from David Cass. I'm going to ask it
because I like it. Um, he said,
"Currently, Congress is considering
legislation to address the trading and
ownership of individual stocks by
members of Congress. What are your views
on this subject?" What are your
I don't think we've had big serious
moral lapses in Congress.
Maybe a fairly scattered minor amount of
minor misgreancy.
So I'm not mo much worried about it.
Uh John Van Eekout wrote in several
questions um all in one email that he's
just asking about US energy
independence. And I'll I'll give you
some of the questions. I won't ask every
one of them, but he says, "Charlie, in
the past you've stated that the USA
should keep all oil and gas production
domestic and let the rest of the world
deplete the supplies of other exporters.
Do you still believe that position has
merit? What's your opinion of pre
President Biden's position on oil and
gas energy production here in the USA
given that he's canceled the Keystone
pipeline and is curtailing drilling on
BL um Bureau of Land Management lands?
Is this just a concession to the
greenhouse to the Green Progressives?
Will we ever have a stable supply of
renewable energy given the issues of
wind power we've seen in Europe? And do
you believe there'll be enough renewable
electric electrical generation capacity
to offset the use of coal and petroleum
to generate electricity?
Well, that's a lot to talk about. There
is no question about the fact that we've
got a lot of renewable
energy we can get from solar and and
wind and that it's gotten pretty
efficient and competitive.
And I am in favor of conserving the
hydrocarbons instead of using them up as
fast as possible.
And I'm in favor of of all this new
generating capacity now that it's gotten
so efficient from solar and wind. And
if there were no global warming problem,
I would be in favor of
exactly what
the government is now doing, which is
encouraging a hell of a lot more solar
and and wind. I think it would be smart
to do that just to conserve the
petroleum. The petroleum has enormous
chemical uses and fertilizers and
chemistry and so on and so on. And it's
it's precious stuff and I don't mind
having a goodly part of it that's
remains in the ground. It's a good place
to store it. I regard the petroleum of
the United States about the way I regard
the black top soil of Iowa. I regard as
a national trees treasure. And just as
I'm not in favor of sending all the top
soil of Africa down and dumping it in
the ocean, I'm not in favor of using up
all the petroleum as fast as possible.
So I love the idea of conserving the
natural resources
and they're all going to be used
eventually
and and I I'm in no hurry to use them up
rapidly.
That is a very unusual attitude, but
it's mine and
and I'm very encouraged by how much
energy we can get that is renewable from
solar and wind with modern technology.
We have a huge potential of getting
renewable energy that way. And I think
now that it's so efficient, we ought to
go ahead and do it.
And but
global warming
I'll be very surprised if global warming
is going to be as bad as people say it's
going to be.
Why?
The temperature of the earth went up
what one degree centigrade in about
200 years.
It it just that's a hell of a lot of
just coal and oil was burned and so
forth and it was one degree. I'm just
skeptical about whether it's as bad as
these calamity howlers are saying.
Got another question that came in from
Tom Seymour and um this one is
Bergkshire recently announced plans for
an in-person annual meeting. What are
yours and Warren's thoughts on COVID and
omocrron both here in the United States
and around the world? And then in terms
of the Berkshire meeting, will attendees
be required to show proof of vaccination
to enter the arena?
Well, I'm not familiar with I think
that's a I'm not sure that's all even
been decided. We're going to make it a
real meeting if we can and that's the
current plan.
What about just your thoughts?
My personal guess and it's just a it's
just a guess and my my personal guess is
it's going to happen.
The other part of that question was just
your your thoughts on COVID and omocrron
here in the United States. Where you
think things stand what we've been
through?
Well, I if we get lucky it'll fade away
to to a minor problem.
How much do
we kill 30,000 people a year with flu
every year in the United States?
Suppose that we're 60,000 and included
amigron. you know, I think we'd we'd get
used to it
kind of in relation to COVID. Um, this
question comes in from Katcha Port Naya
in Westwood, Massachusetts, who says,
"The pandemic has made the difference
between big business and small business
more clear than ever. It also made it
harder for harder than ever for small
businesses to thrive. All businesses
were ordered closed in some states, yet
Home Depot and Shop and Stop were
allowed to operate. Do you think that we
will ever see small businesses have a
more even playing field, or is this a
never-ending spiral down the rabbit hole
until there's nothing but big business
left?
Well, I think we will have small
business as far ahead as you can see.
And [clears throat]
if you stop to think about it, every
shopping center is full of small
business.
And now they're not as flourishing as
they were a while ago. But but we're not
going to get rid of small business in
the United States.
He's I I I
sense we need a big business.
It it makes sense to have something like
Apple and Google as big as they are and
serving as well as they're doing. And
just as I didn't mind AT&T when it ran
the whole television network, I don't
mind Apple or Google being a big
company.
So I'm not I'm not
Russell. I
I'm not worried about having some big
companies and a lot of small ones. I
think that's our system.
You think it's an uneven playing field
right now? The Russell 2000 is more than
15% off its all-time high right now.
It's it's had a pretty rough go,
especially in recent months.
Well, I I
if you stop to think about it, my way in
life was not predicting little
short-term differences between the
Russell
the Russell index and the standard and
pores index. I don't have any opinion
about which index is better at any given
time. I never even think about it. I'm
always just looking for something that's
good enough to put Munger money in
or Bergkshire money in or Daily Journal
money in. And I figure that
I want to swim as well as I can against
the tides. I'm not trying to predict the
tides.
I expect to be suffering
from
well
if you're going to invest in stocks for
the long term or real estate of course
there going to be periods when
there's a lot of agony and other periods
when there's a boom and I think you just
have to learn to live through them and
as Kipling said treat those two
impostors just the same you have to deal
with daylight and night does that bother
tell you very much. No. Sometimes it's
night and sometimes it's daylight.
Sometimes it's a boom. Sometimes it's a
bust. I'm just I I believe in doing as
well as you can and keep going as long
as they let you.
Pauli from Toronto, Canada writes in. It
says, "Do the great tech franchises of
our day, specifically Microsoft, Apple,
and Alphabet, have the same long-term
durability that Coca-Cola had 30 to 40
years ago?"
Well,
of course, it's a lot easier to predict
who flourished in the past because we
know what happened in the past. But now
I want to compare what's going to happen
in the future. Of course, that's harder.
It's very hard for me to imagine.
Doesn't mean it couldn't happen, but
it's I would expect Microsoft and
and
Apple and Alphabet to be strong
50 years from now. Really strong. Still
strong.
But
if you'd asked me when I was young what
was going to happen to the department
stores that went broke, the newspapers
which went broke and so on and so I
wouldn't have predicted that either. So
[clears throat] I think it's hard to
predict
how your world is going to change if
you're going to talk about 70 80 90
years.
Just think, imagine they wiped out the
shareholders of General Motors. They
wiped out the shareholders at Kodak. Who
in the hell would have predicted that?
This technological change can destroy a
lot of people.
And and I think it's hard to predict for
sure
in advance,
but the telephone company is still with
us. It's just it uses a different way of
doing it.
So some things remain and some vanish.
Charlie Jeffrey Mallaloy from San
Francisco writes in. He says much media
attention's been focused on the large
numbers of Americans who've resigned
from their jobs over the last year. What
do you make of this trend and what
advice would you give to CEOs seeking to
retain their employees?
Well, this is a very interesting thing
that the pandemic has given us.
An awful lot of people have gotten used
to not being in the office at five days
a week. And I think a lot of those
people are never going back to five days
a week.
It's amazing the percentage of the
people in computer science that don't
want to be in the office for a normal
life.
uh they want to do a lot of it from
locations that are more convenient to
them. I think a lot of that's going to
remain forever.
I I don't think we're going back to I
don't think the average corporation is
going to fly its directors around so
they can sit at the same table for every
meeting of the year. Maybe they'll have
two meetings where the directors are
together. By the way, Bergkshire's
directors have done that forever.
The Bergkshire directors have met face
to face twice a year forever and done
everything else on the telephone or with
consent minutes and it's worked fine for
Berkshire. I don't think we needed all
these goddamn meetings and airplane
flights. So I think part of what's
happening is quite constructive that
it'll get make life simpler and cheaper
and more efficient.
I don't think we're going back for some
kinds of work.
Now, on the other hand, they get they
made the welfare so liberal just
helicoptering this money out, it was
just hell to even man your restaurant so
you can serve the patrons.
I think we probably overdid that a
little. I think Larry Summers is quite
possibly right that we overshot a little
with some of the stimulus and it would
have been smarter with to do a little
less.
If you stop to think about it,
what makes capitalism work is the fact
that
if you're a able-bodied young person,
if you refuse to work, you suffer a fair
amount of agony.
And and it's because of that agony
that this whole economic system works.
And so
the only
effective economies that we've had that
brought us modernity and the prosperity
we now have, they imposed a lot of
hardship on young people who didn't want
to work.
You take away all the hardship and say
you can stay home and get more than you
you get if you come to work. It's quite
disruptive to an economic system like
ours.
the next time we do this, I don't think
we ought to be quite so liberal.
What about the the last part of that
question where he he asks, "What advice
would you give to CEOs who are seeking
to retain their employees?"
Well, every CEO I know is adapting
somewhat to
some people who work differently.
than they did in the past. So I think
some of these changes are here
here forever.
If your job in life is to get on the
telephone
and talk to other engineers all over the
world while you solve problems, why do
you have to do it from an office?
So I think and and and
the commutes get harder and harder with
more traffic and it's harder and harder
to
to handle more traffic and more people.
It may be a good thing that more people
are going to commute less.
Denny Poland writes in with a question
on compensation plans. He says there's
many examples of public company
executive compensation programs that
produce misaligned outcomes for
executives and for shareholders. What
are some of the most important
compensation related changes investors
and boards of directors could make to
create a better alignment of interest
between the shareholders and the
management
talking about what the economists call
agency problems. If you're managing your
own affairs, you're going to be pretty
efficient because you're taking care of
your own property. If you're working for
somebody else, the truth of the matter
is you care more about yourself and your
future and your family than you care
about the telephone company you're
working for. So,
capitalism is efficient when when the
people are making the decisions are
doing it about their own property
instead of just as hired employees of
some say stateowned enterprise.
That's just the way it is. And
and it's just amazing to me
how
important it is to have a majority of
the property of a civilization owned by
somebody who's in charge of caring for
it. That way the property's properly
taken care of. When the Chinese went
away from collectivist agriculture
and let each peasant have his own plot
of land and he got to keep the crop
after his costs,
the grain production went up 60% the
first year.
Now, who in the hell would want
collectivist agriculture when it was
that inefficient compared to capitalist
agriculture? Well, the Chinese
communists decided the hell with this
communism when it comes to collectivist
agriculture. They'd rather have the
extra 60% in grain production and and
they just changed the whole system. I
greatly admire what they did. I think
Ding Xiaoing is going to go down as one
of the greatest leaders that any nation
ever had because he had to give up his
own ideology to do something else that
worked better. You don't see the
Catholic cardinals suddenly deciding
there's no afterlife.
But that's what Jenoping did. He gave up
his ideology, his communist ideology in
order to make the economy work better.
and being an absolute ruler, he could he
could arrange it and he brought that
whole nation out of poverty and
prosperity and over the course of 30
years after he made the decision.
That is a very admirable thing to have
done. And
and and
it was kind of a miracle.
It's just amazing how well capitalism
has served the communist Chinese. Ding
Joping said called it communism with
Chinese characteristics.
He means he he meant one party
government but with most of the property
in private hands and a fair amount of
free enterprise. That's what he meant
when he said communism with Chinese
characteristics. I don't care what he
calls it. He was right. It was a
marvelous thing to have done for China
and it it worked wonderfully well and of
course we shouldn't be trying to travel
transfer more and more functions to the
government
what they gave up on. We don't want to
go that way. I don't think
a shareholder named Rob writes in. He
says, "How do you value Mr. Gendler and
the SEC's role in protecting the
integrity of the American financial
system.
Integrity of the American financial
Well,
it's hard to fix.
What happens, of course, is that
people rationalize their own way of
making a living. There's some moral
compromise in most
activity that people are in where they
make a living and particularly so in
things like finance and wealth
management and so forth. And of course
the people making the decisions care
more about their own families than they
care about the people whose money
they're managing
because
that's just the way human beings are
constructed.
And and that means that
when you hire somebody else to manage
your money, to take care of your old
age, it's very hard to get the job done
right.
It's very difficult.
And
nowadays,
every director in a big company gets
$300,000 a year. And everybody thinks we
arranged all this wonderful
independence. A man who needs $300,000
extra a year as a director is not an
independent. The one thing you can
guarantee is he'll try and stay a
director.
I don't think that's an ideal system.
And
and yet I don't I don't think there's
anything easy to do about it. I just
think it's hard to get things managed as
well as they should be.
I was in the early days of
my life, I was I worked a little bit on
the fringes of the mo motion
[clears throat] picture industry and I
would say practically everyone sort of
took advantage of the shareholders
and that was just the culture and that
is just deeply into human nature that
people are going to behave that way. And
of course it makes it
makes it hard to run a proper
civilization.
And
if you look at Berkshire and the Daily
Journal, look at the Daily Journal
Corporation.
Charlie Munger age 98, Jerry Salsman,
age 83.
Enormous delegations of powers to Jerry
Salsman. As I say, the Bergkshire
Hathway system of managing a subsidiary
is just short of abdication.
And look at how well it's worked.
Of all the newspapers in the United
States,
most of them are going out of business.
The Wall Street Journal will survive.
The New York Times will survive.
The digital newspaper of Thompson
Reuters will survive.
But mo most of the other newspapers are
going to go out of business.
And
and yet in that climate, this little
Daily Journal Corporation is one
business is dying and we have all this
liquid wealth and marketable securities
and we got another business that we're
trying to make into a respectable big
business. It's quite an achievement. If
there were
500 newspaper companies, there are maybe
two or three that have had a result like
that. And and look at how old the people
are that have done it.
And neither Garren or I ever took one
penny out of the Daily Journal in all
the years we worked here. No director's
fees, no president's fees, no expenses,
no nothing. And Jerry's been a miracle,
wearing five, six different hats at once
and so forth, doing everything and very
little cost. And and Bergkshire has like
30 people in headquarters who aren't
internal auditors. And look at how well
Bergkshire's done.
It's hard to run a bureaucracy that
doesn't get
terrible slowness and terrible waste and
terrible pond and and and
I I I don't know how to
it's a very serious problem.
Just imagine
think of the big bureaucracies that have
died. US Steel, Eastman, Kodak,
Federated Department Stores,
Sears, Robu,
and yet some things have come through
and survived. And in some cases, the
whole business had to die and they had
to take the capital out and we owned a
new businesses just to survive. That's
what Bergkshire did. Look at the three
companies that Bergkshire
had. They all they all went out of
business. And yet we rung enough money
out before they died. Bergkshire now has
more audited net worth on its balance
sheet than any other corporation in the
United States.
Now that's weird.
[laughter] And we don't have this
bureaucracy that other places have.
There isn't anybody at headquarters to
be bureaucratic.
Just a little handful of people are
running an empire.
And
I don't think there's any chance that
the rest of the world is going to be
like Bergkshire.
I think we were kind of a fluke that
lasted for a while and the Daily Journal
is a mini Bergkshire.
What are the chances a little flea
bitten newspaper in Los Angeles would be
as prosperous as it is after all this
trouble which is making all the other
newspapers go broke?
By the way, we're going to miss these
newspapers terribly. Each
newspaper,
all those local monopolies
was an independent bastion of power. The
economic position was so impregnable.
They were all monopolies that the
the propri and the
ethos of the journalist was to try and
tell it like it is.
and and they were really a branch of the
government. They called them the fourth
estate, meaning the fourth branch of the
government. It arose by accident. Now
about 95% of the business can disappear
and go away forever. And what do we get
in substitute? We get a bunch of people
who attract an audience because they're
crazy.
I have my favorite crazies and you have
your favorite crazies and we get
together and all become crazier as we
hire people to tell us what we want to
hear. This is no substitute for Walter
Kankite and and all those great
newspapers of yester year. We we have
suffered a huge loss here. It's nobody's
fault. It's just it's the creative
destruction of capitalism. But it's a
terrible thing that's happened to our
country. And having these new
journalists come in and
and tell the nuts on each side, the
right-wing nuts and the left nuts only
what they want to hear and slant all the
facts so that they hear a lot of stuff
that isn't. So
this is not good for our republic. And I
don't have the faintest idea what to do
about it.
I sometimes think maybe we should have a
third party and almost every state now
doesn't matter whether the Democrats or
the Republicans are in charge.
They rejigger all the maps so everybody
has a safe district
and now we get these permanent careerist
people with their safe districts. The
only fear they have is in the primary
they face a a note who might throw them
out. And so, and every 10 years or so,
the
the nutty rightists and the nutty
leftists get together and maybe they're
10 sane people in the California
legislature. They throw them out.
One group of nuts throws out
the people in the middle and so does the
other. And the one thing they can both
agree on is they don't want any
balanced, sensible people in the
legislature. This is a very peculiar
kind of government. This was not our
ideal when we went to democracy, but
it's what h has happened and it's
getting worse and worse and it's it's
quite serious and I have the fest idea
what we're going to do about it.
That would be my question. Good. Fix it.
That would be my question. How do you
fix
Well, you could have a third party. We
did that once before.
We got rid of slavery and maybe we'll
get a third party. There are rump
sessions. There are members of Congress
who have some little organization. Maybe
there's 40 of them and they say we're
the same core
and they're half Republican and half
Democrats.
The problem.
I I welcome anything like that. We may
need a new party. This thing is getting
so dysfunctional
and the people hate each other so much
that it's just not constructive.
How would you like to have your life as
full of hatred as the as the average
state legislature?
They really don't like or trust each
other at all.
And if you took my generation, my
generation after World War II,
we said politics stop at the water edge.
And we took our enemies.
Japan had marched our soldiers to death
and the baton marched. Hitler had killed
all the Jews and also slaughtered
everybody. And we made our best friends
on earth practically are the Germans and
the Japanese. That was a real
achievement
that can you imagine our legislators has
now constituted doing anything like
that?
No.
Well, with that cheerful thought,
let's go on to some other question.
All right. The next question comes from
John Cox. Uh he's in Cape Cod. He says,
"Mr. Munger, how do you see the value
proposition of college certificates and
degrees for future students and the role
of the federal government in terms of
increasing PEL grants, student loans,
and student debt forgiveness?"
Well, that's a another complicated
subject. And
of course,
one of the glories of modern
civilization is modern education.
The American universities
have been perfectly marvelous
in in in their achievements and modern
technical civilization has been
perfectly marvelous in its achievements
and and we owe a lot to all the free
education
we've provided and we probably ought to
do more of it. However, the way we're
constructed,
other people will,
we've had a lot of for-profit educators
sort of pretended to educate the people
who weren't really very educable and
they send the bills to the federal
government. So, there's been a fair
amount of disreputable
private education
that kind of lures people in with dreams
and cheats them and
and that's not a credable part of of the
past.
But,
but we're going to end it with more
public education.
There's no once you start
a social safety net, everybody wants
more and more of it. The people that
have the loans, they want the loans
forgiven.
It gets to be a big body of people
clamoring for money.
Benjamin Franklin was suspicious of
this. He said that when the citizens of
a republic learn they can vote
themselves money, the end of the
republic is near.
Well, it may not be as near as Benjamin
Franco thought, but it's it's probably
closer we're probably closer to the end
than we were 200 years ago.
It is not good when everybody wants to
get their money by a lot of government
help.
Oought to be not to need any help.
not to maximize his help from the
government.
While we're on the subject of of of
college, this is a question that came
in, I guess, in regards to some of the
controversy that was kicked up. It says,
"What what was it specifically that
prompted the idea for windowless dorm
rooms? Please walk us through this
decision." I guess this is in in regards
to your design for for student housing
with no windows.
the windows.
Nobody in his right mind would prefer a
blank wall
in a bedroom to a bowl with a window in
it. The reason you take the windows out
is you're getting something else from
the design considered as a hole. If you
stop to think about it, a big cruise
ship has a huge shortage of windows and
bedrooms because
too many of the stateaterooms are either
on below the water line or they're on
the wrong side of the aisle. And so in
the very nature of things, you get a
shortage. You can't change the shape of
the ship. You have to do without a lot
of the windows to have a ship that's
functional. That's required by the laws
of hydrodnamics.
And so
we get the advantage of a big ship, but
it means a lot of the state rooms can't
have windows. Similarly, if you want a
bunch of people who are educating each
other to to be conveniently close to one
another, you get a shortage of windows.
And in exchange, you get a whole lot of
people who are getting a lot of
advantage from being near one another.
and they have to do without a real
window in the bedroom. It doesn't
matter. The air can be as pure as you
want it. And the light that comes in
through an artificial window can mimic
the spectrum of daylight perfectly.
And
it's an easy tradeoff. You pay $20,000
a week or something in a big cruise ship
to have a a uh a stateateroom with an
artificial window. And for a long time
on a Disney cruise ship, they had two
different kinds of windows of of uh
stateooms, one with a window and one
without a window. and they charged more
with the one they got a higher price in
rent for the one with an artificial
window than they got for a real one. In
other words, they've reduced the
disadvantage to zero. In fact, they made
it an advantage.
And so
it's it's a game of tradeoffs.
That poor pathetic architect who
criticized me is just an ignoramus.
[laughter]
He can't help himself.
I guarantee the one thing about him,
he's not fixable.
Of course, you have to make tradeoffs in
architecture.
Um,
Charlie, another question came in about
Costco. Um
Ammy Patel from California, you recently
talked about bubbles and high valuations
in your own conference talk. Is Costco a
part of that? Costco has never traded at
a higher price to sales or price to
earnings multiple. How should new
investors think about Costco given its
record run?
Well, that's a very good question and
I've always believed that nothing was
worth an infinite price. So at some even
an admirable place like Costco could get
to a price where you would say that's
too high.
But I would argue that
if I were investing money for some
sovereign wealth fund or some pension
fund
and 30 40 50 year time horizon
I would buy Costco at the current price.
I think it's that strong an enterprise
and that admirable a place.
Now, I'm not saying I would I can't
bring myself with my habits to pay these
big prices, but I never even think about
selling a share of Costco just because
it's selling at a high price.
So,
if you stop to think about it,
[gasps] I bought at Christmas time a
flannel shirt, a bunch of flannel shirts
at Costco. They cost $7 each, more or
less, and it was a soft flannel and it
was better and so forth. And then I
bought pants. I think they were Orvis
pants. And I paid like $7. They stretch
around my waist and they're partly water
resistant, what have you.
Costco is going to be an absolute titan
on the internet because they got curated
products that everybody trusts and huge
purchasing power on a limited number of
stocking units.
So,
I'm not worried about I I I'm not saying
I'm buying Costco at this price, but I'm
certainly not selling any.
I think it's going to be a big powerful
company as long as far ahead as you can
see. And I think it deserves its
success.
I think it has a a good culture
and a good
moral ethos. And so,
I wish everything else in America is
working as well as Costco does.
Think what a blessing that would be for
us all.
Um, Michael Wterly writes in and he
says, "Can you please update us,
Charlie, on your view of 3G capital and
zerobased budgeting? Has your thinking
evolved over the last five years?"
Well, of course, if you have a very rich
corporation,
human nature, what it is, it'll get a
lot of bureaucracy and a lot of excess
cost in it and a lot of meetings and so
forth.
And there's huge waste in that. In fact,
a lot of the extra meetings make you
worse off, not better off. So, you're
not only spending a lot of extra money.
It's not that you aren't getting as much
as you're paying for.
It's where
many places after they've rung out 30%
of the excess costs, they run better
than they did before.
In other words,
getting rid of the people and changing
things around that runs better, not
worse. So, there's a lot of overmanning
in big successful places. And of course,
uh,
it's human nature that people kind of
relax a little when they get prosperous
and so forth. And I know a corporation,
I have a friend who was on a corporation
with headquarters in Europe and they
would fly him from Los Angeles to Europe
on a Concord.
It cost them $100,000 to take one
director to Los Angeles to Germany and
back. I mean, the excess just creeps
into these places and of course it isn't
good. And and
on the other hand, you can cut too much
and there should be some mercy for
people who've been around a long time
and have served well in the past.
So you you don't necessarily want a 100%
perfect efficiency,
but
but you you wouldn't want a rule that
nobody could ever go to some overman
place and cut out a lot a lot of the
fat.
The director's table in the Hines
Corporation cost $600,000.
The goddamn director's table. The
director's table in Costco cost about
$300.
They're different places, different
ethos.
And of course, if you get fat like that,
somebody like 3G comes along and says,
"I want to buy you and cut you back to
normal."
And and of course if it's possible to
overcut,
but
my guess is there's
there's a lot of fat in our successful
places. There's a lot of think of the
fat on the average rich family.
U Charlie, another question from Mike
Branch. should just ask.
I don't think we want I don't think we
want unlimited fat in these places. And
the other hand, we don't want too much
brutality and too much
it's complicated like everything else.
Um this other question is what impact
does passive investing had on stock
valuations?
What kind of investing?
Passive investing.
Passive
passive investing. Oh, huge. That is
that's another thing that's coming.
We have a new bunch of emperors and
they're the people who vote the shares
in the index funds.
Maybe we can make Larry Frink and the
people at Vanguard Pope.
All of a sudden, we've had this enormous
transfer of voting power to these
passive index funds. that is going to
change the world.
And I don't know what the consequences
are going to be, but I predict it will
not be good.
I think the world of Larry Fank, but I'm
not sure I want him to be my emperor.
[laughter]
Um, here's another question that comes
in. Um, this is a tough one, too. Um
this is from Charles Francis who writes,
"Please ask Charlie who will fill the
gap of lending to global governments
after quantitative easing ends. As an
example, um as FOMC paper matures and
rolls off their balance sheet, where
will the additional money needed to run
governments come from? Who's the lender
and at what expected rate?"
Um please remember the FOMC has always
been municipal debt. What's the
solution?
Municipal debt.
Is he talking about the China or the
United States?
United States. I think he's talking
specifically United States. I think he's
talking specifically.
That's a big problem because the
government has been living by land sales
and of course they've had a boom.
They're having to shrink that sector a
little. So it's it's creating an awkward
problem.
In the United States,
we have a hugely strong economy in a
hugely strong technical civilization
and that's not going away
and the knowledge and so forth. And you
can't believe
what a modern factory looks like when
you fill it with robots.
And that's coming more and more and
more. And it's coming to China too for
that matter. And so those trends are
inevitable.
And I don't know how it's all going to
play out. But I think it does create
adjustment problems. If you have a fine
unionized job and they replace you with
a yot, a robot, you've got a difficult
problem.
If you got a company like Kodak and they
invent something new that obsolates your
product,
you have a problem too and you solve
that by dying.
A lot of people don't like that
solution. I don't much care for it
myself.
All right. This question comes in from
Peter North from Woolwitch, Maine.
Um he says prior to the pandemic it
seemed like the US was getting used to
borrowing and running revenue deficits
of close to 20%. There are all kinds of
reasons for this through multiple
administrations of either party. Now
we're marching closer to the well-known
demographic storm that will drive
deficits still higher. He estimates that
we are currently running about a 33%
total deficit if you include unfunded
future social security and Medicare
obligations. Meanwhile, we're headed to
higher interest rate costs on top of our
30 trillion in debt. Today, interest
comprises 6% of our spending, and the
potential to double or triple interest
expense is only going to make the
problem worse. How can we get the
public, companies, and politicians to
recognize the seriousness of this
problem and begin to take action?
Well,
because all those problems are real
and because it's so tempting to get rid
of your debt by just
giving a guy a non-interest bearing
checking account where you used to have
to pay him interest every month.
Not only do we have a serious problem,
but the solution to it that is the
easiest for the politicians and for the
Federal Reserve too for that matter is
just to print more money and solve the
temporary problems that way. And that of
course is going to have some long-term
dangers.
And
and we know what happened
in Germany when they when the Weimar
Republic just kept printing money. The
whole thing blew up and that was a
contributor to the rise of Hitler. So
all this stuff is dangerous and serious
and we don't want to have a bunch of
politicians just doing whatever is easy
on the theory that it didn't hurt us
last time so we can double it and do it
one more time and then we double it
again and so forth. We know what happens
on that
everlasting doubling doubling doubling.
you will have a very different
government if you keep doing that
enough.
And so you're flirting with danger
somewhere
unless there's
some discipline in the process.
But I don't regard Japan as in some
terrible danger. Having they they've
done a huge amount of this and gotten by
with it. I don't think we'll be as good
at handling our problems as Japan is.
Frank Wang from Houston writes in and
says, "If taxes were not an issue, what
are your thoughts on going to cash today
and waiting for better opportunities to
deploy that cash over the next 12
months? Is it a sensible idea in your
mind?"
In my whole adult life, I've never
hoarded cash waiting for better
conditions.
I've just invested in the best thing I
could find. And I don't think I'm going
to change now. And the Daily Journal's
used up its cash. Now, Bergkshire has
excess cash,
quite a bit of excess cash,
but it's not doing that because it knows
thinks it knows how to time investments.
it he just can't find anything it can
stand by.
So we don't have a solution to your
problem. We we're just coping with it as
I've described.
Uh VJV writes in on that very point.
Given the valuation and and market
correction in early 2020, why is
Bergkshire not picking up or adding any
new companies to its profile? Is the
management getting too conservative with
M&A? Of course, kudos to the team in
picking up Apple shares a couple of
years back. That's paying off for sure.
No,
it the the the reason we're not buying
things, we can't buy anything at prices
we're willing to pay.
It's just that simple.
Other people are bidding the price up.
And a lot of the buying is not by people
who really plan to own them. A lot of it
is feed driven buying. Private equity
buys things so they can have more fees
by having more things under management.
Of course, it's a lot easier to buy
something if you use somebody else's
money. We're using our own money. At
least that's the way we think of it. And
and so
so
but we're not,
by the way, it's not a tragedy that
Bergkshire has some surplus money
they're not investing.
And you can argue that the little old
Daily Journal, what what a good thing it
was. We had 30 million extra coming in
from a foreclosure boom and and that we
invested it shrewdly. It gives us a lot
of flexibility. And by the way, that
piled up money helps us in wooing these
governmental bodies we're selling the
software to.
We look more responsible with the extra
wealth. And we are more responsible with
the extra wealth.
But if
the shareholders who are worried about
the future because it looks complicated
and difficult and they're hazard, I want
to say to them what my old torch
professor said to me, Charlie, he'd say,
"Charlie, tell me what your problem is,
and I'll try and make it more difficult
for you." [laughter]
And he did me a favor by treating me
that way.
And
and I'm just repeating his favor to you.
When you're thinking the thoughts you're
doing, at least you're thinking in the
right direction. You're worried about
the right things. All you people that
are worried about the inflation and the
future of the republic and so forth.
Uh Mickey and Michael Fontinet wrote in
uh seeking advice for a 22-year-old
investing growth uh or monthly income
from div to get the monthly income from
dividends. They say they have a
22-year-old brilliant young neighbor.
He's achieved an internship at Tesla and
GE and is currently a student at Purdue.
He takes advantage of his 37 years, his
neighbor's 37 years in the oil field.
The neighbor takes advantage of his
techsavvy in Reddit and the meme crowd.
Uh his inclination is to advise him to
continually slow drip into monthly
income and dividend investing as opposed
to swinging for the fences in AI and
growth stocks. What would you advise,
sir?
Well, I don't think I have a
one-sizefititall investment for I think
some people are gifted enough that they
can invest in in
hard to value difficult things. Other
people, I think, would be very wise to
have more modest ambitions in terms of
what they choose to deal with. So I
think you have to figure out your level
of skill or the level of skill your
advisor has and that should enter the
equation.
But
to everyone who finds the current
investment
climate hard and difficult and somewhat
confusing,
I would say welcome to adult life
and you're thinking the right thing. Of
course, it is hard. It's going to be way
harder
for the group that is not that
graduating from college now. For them to
get rich and stay rich and so forth,
it's going to be way harder for them
than it was for my generation.
Think what it costs to own a house in a
desirable neighborhood in a city like
Los Angeles.
It's not a
and I think we'll probably end up with
higher income taxes too and so on.
No, I I think the investment world is
plenty hard. And I don't think the
in my lifetime, 98 years,
it was the ideal time to own a
diversified portfolio of common stocks
that updated a little by adding the new
ones that came in like the Apples and
the Alphabets and so forth. And
I'd say the people got maybe 10 or 11%
if you did that very intelligently
before inflation and maybe 9% a after
infl eight eight or nine% that was a
marvelous return that no other
generation in the history of the world
ever got returns like that and I don't
think the future is going to
give the guy graduating from college
this year
nearly that easy an investment
opportunity. I think it's going to be
way harder.
This question comes in from Steve who
says, "What worries you most about our
economy and the stock market? And on the
other hand, what makes you optimistic?"
Well, you have to be optimistic about
the competency of our technical
civilization.
But there again, it's an interesting
thing. If you take the last
100 years
1922 to 2022
most of modernity came in in that 100
years
and then the previous 100 years
that got another big chunk of modernity
and before that things were pretty much
the same for the previous
thousands of years.
Life was pretty brutal and short and
limited and
what have you. No printing press, no air
conditioning, no modern medicine, no
so
and
I don't think we're going to get things
that were
in what I call the real human needs.
Think of what it meant to get
say first you got the steam engine, the
steam ship, the railroad
and a little bit of improvement with
farming and a little bit of improvement
in plumbing. That's what you got in the
in the 100 years that ended in 1922.
The next hundred years gave us
widely distributed electricity, modern
medicine, marital,
the automobile, the airplane, the the
records, the movies, the air
conditioning in the south. And think
what a blessing it was. If you wanted
five children, I mean, if you wanted six
children, if you wanted three children,
you had to have six because three died
in infancy. That was our ancestors.
Think of the agony of watching half your
children die.
It just, it's amazing how much
achievement there's been in civilization
in these last 200 years, and most of it
in the last hundred years. Now the
trouble with the disease is is that the
basic needs
are pretty well filled
in the United States. The principal
problem of the poor people is they're
too fat. That is a very different place
from what happened in the past. The the
past they were on the edge of starving.
And and what happens is it's really
interesting is with all this enormous
increase in living standards and freedom
and diminishment of racial inequities
and all the huge progress that has come.
People are less happy about the state of
affairs than they were when things were
way tougher.
And that has a very simple explanation.
The world is not driven by greed.
It's driven by envy.
And so
the fact that everybody's five times
better off than they used to be, they
take it for granted. All they think
about is somebody else has having more
now. And it's not fair that he should
have it and they don't. That's the
reason that God came down and told Moses
that you couldn't envy your neighbor's
wife or even his donkey.
I mean, even the the old Jews were
having trouble with envy. And so, it's
built into the nature of things.
It's weird for somebody my age because I
was in the middle of the Great
Depression. The hardship was
unbelievable.
I was safer walking around Omaha in the
evening than I am in my own neighborhood
in Los Angeles after all this great
wealth and so forth. So, and I I have no
way of doing anything about it. I can't
change the fact that a lot of people are
very unhappy and feel very abused after
everything's improved by about 600%.
Because there's still somebody else who
has more. I have conquered envy in my
own life. I don't envy anybody. I don't
give a damn what somebody else has. But
other people are driven crazy by it.
and other people play to the envy in
order to advance their own
uh uh political careers.
And we have whole networks now that are
that they want to pour gasoline on the
flames of envy.
I I like the religion of the old Jews. I
I like the people who were against envy,
not the people who were trying to profit
from it.
But if you stop, think of the
pretentious expenditures of the rich.
Who in the hell needs a real Rolex watch
so you can get mugged for it? You know,
I mean, it's
yet everybody wants to have a
pretentious expenditure and that helps
drive demand in our modern capitalist
society.
My advice to the young people is don't
go there.
the hell of the pretentious expenditure.
I don't think there's much happiness in
it.
But it it does drive the civilization we
actually have
and Jerry Miller
it drives the dissatisfaction.
Go ahead.
Steve Pinker of Harvard is one of our
smart modern AC academics. He constantly
points out how everything's gotten way
way way better. But the general feeling
about how fair it is has gotten
way more hostile.
And as it gets better and better, people
are less and less satisfied.
That is weird, but that's what's
happened.
Jerry Miller from Hobart, Wisconsin
writes in and he's looking back at your
journey through life with Warren
Buffett. He says, "What's the toughest
moment you've shared with Warren? And of
course, what's the very best memory
you've shared during your life with him?
You two seem like you are brothers by a
different mother. May God continue to
bestow his blessings on you. Together,
you're one of the United States of
America's greatest treasures. And
individually, you ain't too bad either.
Well,
God is about to give a different kind of
a blessing
on Ward and me. He's going to give us
whatever afterlife there is.
And of course, nobody knows anything
about that. And
it's been a great run. Warren and I
Warren and I have had a great run. And
one of the really great things about it
is that
we've been surrounded by wonderful
people. The people we've shared in our
work lives and
what Jerry and I have done in this
little business has been a pleasure,
hasn't it, Jerry?
Yes, sir. It's been a it's been a
privilege to do it and a privilege to be
here and so forth and and we haven't had
a dumb bureaucracy like a lot of other
places and we've managed to cope pretty
well with the problems that came to us
and the opportunities too and so we've
been blessed and
it's all old-fashioned virtue. It's
Jerry and I don't have any secrets.
We tend to get the day's work done and
be as rational as we can and coping with
whatever we have to cope with and
and and
that will always work for people who get
good at it.
that Warren and I have been very
fortunate and and of course there are
lessons you can learn from our
there are so many people that
live surrounded by tyranny. There are a
lot of bosses in the world that are
absolutely impossible to be under.
They're really psychotic
and you really can't do anything about
it in many many cases.
Warren and I haven't had those problems.
That's a blessing.
Charlie, another viewer writes in Kumar.
He says, "You seem extremely happy and
content. What's your secret to lead a
happy life?"
Well, I always say the same thing.
Realistic
expectations which is low expectations.
I if you if you have unreasonable
demands on life, you're almost you're
like a bird that's trying to destroy
himself by bashing his wings on the edge
of the cage and you really can't get out
of the cage. It's stupid.
You want to have reasonable expectations
and and take life's results good and bad
as they happen
uh with a certain amount of stoicism.
There'll never be any shortage of good
people in the world.
All you got to do is sink them out and
get as many of them as possible into
your life and keep the rest of the hell
out.
Got a couple of questions left. This one
comes from Wes Roddy in Miami, Florida.
He says, "In your storyried investor
career, which investment did you like
the most and why? And which one was a
dog?"
Well, that's rather interesting.
One of the investments
that nobody ever talks about at
Bergkshire is the World Book
Encyclopedia.
I grew up on it. You know, they used to
sell it doortodoor
and that thing was they had every word
in the English language graded for
comprehension and it had a vast amount
of editorial input. So, it was easy for
a child who wasn't necessarily a
brilliant student to understand that
encyclopedia. It was more
understandable.
And Bergkshire made $50 million a year
pretext out of that business for years
and years and years. And I was always so
proud of it because I grew up with it
and it helped me and so forth. And of
course, I like the 50 million a year.
And then a man named Bill Gates came
along and he decided he's going to give
away a free
encyclopedia with every damn bit of
software in his personal computer
software.
And away went our $50 million a year.
Now we still sell the encyclopedia to
libraries. Maybe we make a few million a
year doing that. But most of the wealth
just went away and all that wonderful
constructive product and
it's still a marvelous product
and it wasn't good that we lost what
worldbook was doing for the civilization
and I was so proud of World Book when
when we but now it's just it's pretty
well gone away in terms of its worldly
significant and the money went with it.
That's just the way capitalism works.
you just it has destruction and some of
the things you lose you're really going
to miss and you're not going to replace
them.
I don't think these TV programs that
charm our children are as good as the
World Book was for them. World Book
helped me get ahead in life
and and the people who aren't going to
read the World Book and who are hanging
in front of the TV set, they're not
blessed, they're cursed. Now there are
advantages too and they're having a
television.
And and Charlie, a final question for
you. This one comes from Matt Mallister.
I'm not weeping any tears that I don't
have my world book anymore.
[laughter]
I've I've adjusted.
I miss it. But I
This last question comes from Matt
Mallister and he says, "First of all, he
wants to thank you for sharing your
wisdom so graciously and generously, but
he says, "Of the five people or so you
most admire, could you please name a few
so that we might become more familiar
with and potentially learn from these
individuals?"
Well, I don't have any one person that I
admire. I would argue that the greatest
governmental
leader whose life overlap mine was Lee
Kuanu of Singapore.
And
I would argue that
he was the one that taught Ding Chaoping
of China how to fix China the way
Singapore fixed itself.
And so it was a huge achievement. So
I've seen some remarkable I think the
Marshall Plan that my country did after
World War II was a marvelous thing and
that was credit to the human race.
I've seen a lot that I'm proud of.
On the other hand,
I see a lot now that I'm not proud of. I
don't like this
crazy hatred in our
party system.
I'm
I don't see anything wrong with having a
goodsized government safety net that
goes up as GD.
I think we'd be crazy to be as rich as
we are without a good governmental
safety net.
By the way, you know where that came
from? Otto Bismar.
He was the iron chancellor of Germany
exercising the unlimited power of a
German king.
Uh that's who gave us social security
and so forth. Nobody thinks of Otto
Bismar as a great hero of democratic
capitalism, but he really was.
Shows how complicated life is.
Strange things happen.
My hero, Otto Bismar. I've never seen
Otto Bismar's picture on an American
wall.
He should be there.
Well, Becky, have you had enough?
Yes. Um, Charlie, want to thank you very
much for your time today. Jerry, thank
you, too. And, uh, thank everybody for
all the questions today.
Um, appreciate everybody coming to the
daily journal meeting.
Happened daily.
It isn't that we want to be the guru for
the world or something. We used to know
all the shareholders and we felt they
only come in once a year. we ought to at
least stand here and answer answer
questions. And they started asking these
odd questions and we kept answering it
and there was a market for it. We kept
doing it. So Warren and I are artificial
accidental gurus
and
it
I used to be sort of bothered by it
because I don't ordinarily make this
many pronouncements,
but I've gotten used to it and I hope
you people have too. [laughter]
We have.
All right. I guess we're through.
We We are. I want to thank everybody for
coming and we should send it back over
to Karina at Yahoo Finance. But
gentlemen, thank you and thanks to
everybody else out there, too.
Okay. All right. Thank you so much. And
you've been watching Yahoo Finance's
special coverage of the Daily Journal's
annual meeting held in Los Angeles. And
if you missed any part of what was a
riveting discussion, you can catch a
full recap of the event at yahoo
finance.com. A great conversation,
Alexis.
Always a treat to hear the candid
remarks there from Charlie Mer. One of
the key takeaways for me, a key to a
happy life, have low expectations. Stick
with us. Lots more Yahoo Finance Live to
come right after this.